ah
socialistas comunistas verdes y también
los integrantes de francia- insumisa
consiguieron ponerse de acuerdo y
conformar una coalición de izquierda
algo que no se veía desde hace varios
años 20 años como mínimo en el escenario
político francés dadas las fracturas
también las diferencias internas que no
les permitía llegar a un acuerdo el
pacto es liderado por francia en su misa
del ex candidato presidencial jean luc
mélenchon y se llama nueva unión popular
ecologista y social que es lo que buscan
pues lo obvio arrebatar la mayoría
parlamentaria que sostiene
renacimiento que es el partido del
reelegido presidente manuel marco que a
propósito este partido cambió de nombre
hace también unas pocas semanas sobre la
conformación de esta coalición de
izquierda les damos más datos de
contexto en el siguiente informe veamos
el acuerdo su oficial el partido
socialista francés ratificó una alianza
de coalición de izquierdas que espera
desafiar al presidente emmanuel manjón
en las elecciones parlamentarias de
junio tras horas de debates a veces
tensos una amplia mayoría de los
miembros del consejo votaron a favor
vamos a tener que avanzar a partir de
ahora jean-luc mélenchon ha asumido una
gran responsabilidad de esta noche ahora
es la única esperanza para la izquierda
y los ecologistas ecologistas jean-luc
mélenchon que ha perdido en la primera
vuelta de las presidenciales de abril
busca la mayoría de los diputados los
socialistas en los verdes en los
comunistas y el partido la francia
insumisa de milán son calificaron el
acuerdo como histórico pero no todo el
mundo está satisfecho aún con divisiones
en el seno del partido socialista
socialista soy socialista y el liderazgo
ligado a la insumisa no cambiará es el
enemigo del socialismo el ex presidente
francés françois hollande también ha
manifestado su firme oposición al
acuerdo al igual que las elecciones en
los comicios legislativos en las 577
circunscripciones de francia funcionan
con un sistema de dos vueltas lo que
significa que las alianzas ofrecen unas
mejores posibilidades de llegar a la
segunda ronda la cohabitación forzada
entre maicon y mélenchon sería la
primera en dos décadas aunque los
expertos ven ese escenario como poco
probable
toda esta estrategia de la izquierda
francesa se ha puesto ya en marcha y se
pondrá a prueba en las elecciones
legislativas del 12 y del 19 de junio a
través de una lista unificada que
representa entonces está alianza para la
política francesa cómo se preparan los
del centro y los de la derecha para
estas elecciones podrá esta coalición de
izquierda mantenerse en el tiempo o será
simplemente una coalición coyuntural les
afectará a las divisiones que hay al
interior por ejemplo del partido
socialista en cuyas bases y entre sus
caras más veteranas hubo muchas
discrepancias en cuanto a la propuesta
de entrar a esta alianza la carrera por
la mayoría la asamblea nacional francesa
ha comenzado y la histórica coalición de
izquierda es el panorama político actual
francés y por eso vamos a analizarlo en
el debate de france 24 para analizar
este tema saludamos a hoy y ricard ella
es analista experta en relaciones
internacionales es docente e
investigadora de la universidad
externado de colombia nos acompaña aquí
en el estudio de france 24 y desde parís
nos acompaña pascal ojo
es analista político y especialista en
relaciones internacionales aquí en salud
de la capital francesa ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en el debate con todos sus comentarios y
las preguntas que quieren hacer sobre
este tema lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram también en
twitter estamos como france24
s santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas
relacionadas con este tema comienzo
entonces en el estudio de france 24
preguntándole ausín una cara conocida ya
parada muchos de los televidentes de
france 24 bienvenida y eugene 20 años
sin una verdadera unión de la izquierda
en francia que representa entonces esta
coalición bueno es verdad que es una
unión un poquito excepcional pero
digamos que también la situación
excepcional no olvidemos el excelente
resultado de sonic - son la presidencia
desde esta misma noche ha dicho quiero
ser primer ministro de francia eligen me
como primer ministro bueno es una
metáfora los franceses no eligen el
primer ministro lo designa presidente
sin embargo los franceses votan por las
elecciones legislativas y el grupo que
es dominante en el parlamento entonces
pues el jefe de este grupo se convierte
un poquito de manera obligatoria en
primer ministro entonces tenemos una
unión de una izquierda que puede parecer
muy heterogénea pero que se encontró
para finalmente ponerse de acuerdo que
queremos el poder no lo logramos en la
presidencia lo vamos a lograr en el
gobierno e incluso si no podemos lograr
la mayoría queremos volvernos la
principal cara de la oposición al
presidente macro le hago la misma
pregunta como punto de partida de este
debate a pascal en la ciudad de parís
bienvenido al programa gracias por
acompañarnos hoy 20 años sin esta
verdadera formación o coalición o
alianza de los partidos de izquierda que
representa para la política para la
actualidad francesa
bueno definitivamente es un momento
clave ahora cuando usted dice 20 años es
cierto que en
1997 la izquierda se unió fue una
izquierda plural con eje central el
partido socialista 20 años después
estamos en otro esquema donde el eje
central de la nueva unión y parece una
unión momentánea para las elecciones
legislativas que ocurren en junio ya el
polo central es la fuerza política
radical de jolie el ojo es decir que ahí
el esquema político de izquierda a
totalmente cambiado
por cierto son la unción llegó a la
tercera posición durante la elección
presidencial logró unos 21 puntos 95% de
los votos
recuerdo la candidata de la extrema
derecha llegó a la segunda vuelta con 23
% 15 y el presidente reelegido obtuvo 27
punto 85 por ciento pero los demás
partidos ahí sí fue han tenido
resultados muy bajos me refiero por
ejemplo al partido socialista cuya
candidata a la alcaldesa de parís la
sierra hidalgo logró un a obtener
1.74 por ciento es dice que estamos en
un esquema totalmente nuevo inédito y lo
metemos muy bien a las proposiciones
que están hechas y alrededor de las
cuales se constituyó esa nueva unión
popular ecológica y social hago la
vuelta a la inversa continúo con pascal
en la ciudad de parís quiero que
profundicemos en cuanto a los temas que
está proponiendo esta coalición de
izquierda los puntos en común que tienen
estos partidos para proponer muchos han
dicho que tal vez este programa tiene un
protagonismo de las propuestas de
francia- insumisa que lograron digamos
sobreponerse a las otras propuestas de
los partidos que análisis hace usted
pascal
bueno por cierto primero diría es una
visión
y no es la primera vez que la izquierda
se une récord de monos de
1936 en los años 70
1972 con un programa común entre partido
socialista comunista en 97 línea lo
hablamos y ahora ahora por cierto hay
una visión una voluntad de una cierta
apreciación de la sociedad de francia en
la unión europea de francia en el mundo
con unos temas
radicalmente diferentes de las
proposiciones hechas lo dijo por la
plataforma que
debería ser la próxima mayoría
presidencial
renacimiento es una plataforma
favorecida por emanuel marco en temas
sociales una revalorización de los
salarios
bajos del mínimo del salario
una diferencia sobre el papel en la
unión europea' permitiéndose no respetar
unas leyes unos acuerdos comunes por
ejemplo dan tantas hay apreciaciones
que marcan diferencias de simplemente de
obviamente al nivel constitucional
charlie melancon llama a una sexta
república ya que en francia estamos
viviendo bajo las reglas de la quinta
república creada en 1958 claro eso al
poder de dolor
y aquí en el estudio el gene su opinión
su perspectiva y análisis de estos temas
que propone esta coalición de izquierda
puntos en común y si usted está de
acuerdo en que francia insumisa está tal
vez imponiendo un poco más sus ideas y
propuestas por encima de los otros sí
sin duda france e insumisa es la que
manda en esta coalición pues las
legislativas mostraron cuáles son las
fuerzas y el sonic - o está muy fuerte y
además de todos los temas que ha
mencionado nuestro invitado también hay
uno muy importante que es lo que
llamamos la transición ecológica o el
cambio climático eso ha sido una de las
grandes temáticas de la francia insumisa
durante su campaña y se ha estimado que
el gobierno de manuel me ha hecho muy
poquito y sigue favoreciendo lo que
decía - o la francia de los lobbies es
decir del lobby petrolero del que hay
mucho más que hacer entonces sobre esta
cuestión de la de la transición
ecológica y además un tema que también
es muy peleado que es la reforma al
sistema pensional younis - yo está
proponiendo una una pensión a los 60
años lo que le vale muchas críticas por
parte del centro de la derecha diciendo
que finalmente es un a muy poca
credibilidad que va a ser muy caro de
financiar a eugene continuó con usted
aquí en el estudio hablemos de lo que
significan estas coaliciones de
izquierda para la política francesa
pascal hablaba de ese frente popular de
1936 y el programa común de la izquierda
de 1972 hoy el escenario es
completamente diferente pero vemos que
también el contexto en el que está
francia a nivel internacional es
diferente una cosa es la elección del
presidente de la reelección de macro de
maco debido a la coyuntura en la que
está europa y otra cosa lo que quieren
los franceses verdaderamente para su
país aquí se pueden notar esas dos
francias distintas en estas elecciones y
puede que esto le favorezca hasta a este
pacto izquierda si puede ser lo que no
hay que olvidar es que cuando nos
encontramos una situación de
cohabitación es dice que el presente es
de un color político y que el gobierno
es de otro color político porque en las
instituciones manda tenemos un este
sistema de cohabitación a los franceses
les encanta este sistema de cohabitación
porque tienen la sensación que pueden
tener la derecha y la izquierda al mismo
chip sin embargo eso genera un problema
de gobernabilidad por ejemplo el
presidente manda en todas asuntos que
tienen que ver con el estado en exterior
por ejemplo pero el primer ministro
sobre la política interior sin embargo
en la unión europea hay muchas
cuestiones que se discuten dentro de la
unión europea que tiene repercusiones
también para la política interior
entonces en este caso de cohabitación
tendríamos un primer ministro que
viajaría con el presidente en estas
cumbres europeas y tendríamos dos caras
para francia porque efectivamente cada
uno estaría peleando por una política
diferente entonces aquí tendríamos un
problema de gobernabilidad para él para
el presidente y podría favorecer digamos
efectivamente esta coalición de
izquierda para luchar sobre un programa
que sea diferente al nivel europeo a
nivel europeo
pascal le abro la pregunta también si
usted quiere añadir algo sobre este
punto y también le preguntó sobre las
recientes elecciones presidenciales que
mostraron como siempre los resultados
dejan en evidencia el estado de los
partidos políticos no solamente en
francia sino en todas las democracias
donde hay votaciones y elecciones
abiertas qué evaluación hace uno después
de estas elecciones del estado de
francia insumisa qué
a liderar esta coalición a moverse de
primera para conformar esta alianza esta
coalición para estas elecciones
parlamentarias
bueno creo que estamos en francia como
bien lo dijo en la verdad en el mundo en
un momento paradójico
las elecciones presidenciales
permitieron la reelección
confortable de manuel macro que obtuvo
más de 58 por ciento de los votos
imagine le pen obtuvo 41 por ciento una
gran diferencia entre ambos
el tercer que no llegó a ese una vuelta
fue por cierto yo ni me lo creo y a la
vez está a la vez mientras vemos es el
funcionamiento democrático
existe una violencia
lo vimos en 2019 a través
del tema de las de las camisas amarillas
esa violencia
revela una forma de fractura la fractura
social una fractura territorial
una fractura en materia de educación de
formación de preparación y ahí está el
desafío ahí está ese punto paradójico de
un país que hoy en día
encabeza por cierto el consejo europeo
que hace parte de los países
más ricos del mundo pero si existe un
malestar
pero la elección presidencial a la vez
monstruo pues una reelección confortable
un malestar político que permitió no a
salir melón son llegar a la segunda
vuelta que permitió a la extrema derecha
llegar a hacer una buena y ahí estamos
pues con ese esa situación que se
perpetúa en víspera de las próximas
elecciones legislativas dentro de menos
de cuatro semanas
mientras las encuestas de opinión que
están revelando están mostrando que la
plataforma presidencial
renacimiento que compone de esquilar un
pilar de el partido de manuel marco de
un partido de centroderecha
horizonte un partido del centro el
modelo ganarían la mayoría todas las
encuestas hoy en día estemos pruden es
una elección es una elección nunca está
ganada por
ante adelante pero se proyecta una
mayoría una mayoría
absoluta es decir más de doscientos
ochenta y nueve
curules en esa mayoría se un componente
de izquierda pero una izquierda plural
hoy en día estamos hablando de una unión
de la izquierda porque estamos en
campaña pero bien se dijo que cada
miembro de esa izquierda plural
tendrá su propia su propia fracción en
la próxima asamblea es decir pues que a
la vez existe este juego político y
ahora ves existe un malestar en la
opinión de que vivimos a través muchos
actos de violencia en la calle se oyen
tomando un poco lo que dice pascal de
las encuestas no vamos a dar cifras de
lo que de lo que dicen los números allí
en francia pero pero muchos no le
auguran tampoco mucho éxito a esta
coalición
tradicionalmente el partido o la
coalición que lidera el partido del
presidente en la que se lleva la mayoría
de escaños en la asamblea si de hecho
por eso la elección legislativa justo es
después de la elección presidencial es
para dalí generalmente una
gobernabilidad al presidente es verdad
que para la esta coalición de izquierda
hay varios desafíos
primero la abstención puede jugar en
favor de manuel marco digamos que manuel
más con está motivando ahí la gente y
sus candidatos ha dicho que tenía que
hacer campaña de día de noche
y esta abstención podría digamos
penalizar un poquito esta está izquierda
además es un sufragio de dos vueltas es
decir que pasan en segunda vuelta a
todos los candidatos que tienen más de
12,5 por ciento significa que puede
haber una sesión willax varios
candidatos para la segunda vuelta
obviamente el hecho de que la izquierda
se haya unido en un solo candidato pues
eso les puede funcionar pero no
olvidamos también que esta izquierda
plural efectivamente es una alianza
coyuntural y que después de esta
elección pues cada uno podría tomar
retomar su disciplina de partido e
además es una unión entre partidos que
no son muy fuertes pues tenemos fila con
sanz su mix que es fuerte pero el
partido socialista no lo es el partido
comunista no lo es el partido ecologista
es mucho menos fuerte de lo que pensaba
entonces también tiene muchos muchos
desafíos lo que sí es interesante es que
manuel mccomb ha designado a esta
alianza de izquierda como su enemigo a
derrotar mientras que en la elección
presidencial
indep en lo que está demostrando eso que
finalmente la izquierda que ha sido más
débil que la extrema derecha a nivel
territorial tiene mucho más enclave
territorial y que imagine lepén si
cristaliza mucho la gente alrededor de
su figura pero no tiene mucho peso
digamos para estas elecciones
legislativas y el juego político aquí ya
cara a las parlamentarias es
completamente diferente en términos de
estrategia usted menciona eugene el
partido socialista que en algunos medios
franceses pues hablaban que
prácticamente a verse al haberse unido a
esta coalición como que le decía adiós a
ese quinquenio de françois hollande y el
ex presidente incluso salió rechazando
estas esta forma de involucrarse en las
parlamentarias de meterse a través de
una coalición y lo declaró en varios
medios de comunicación que esto marcaría
la desaparición del partido socialista
en francia está así de mal políticamente
el partido que hasta francia holanda lo
sentenció a muerte con esta coalición
hay dos visiones hay unos que han dicho
que hoy y jefa que es el primer
secretario del partido socialista acción
muy ingenuo y que definitivamente las
localidades sobre los cuales tiene su
candidato del partido socialista
son muy poquitas y con poca posibilidad
de quedar elegidos y hay otros que han
dicho era eso o el partido socialista
iba definitivamente a ser enterado en
estas elecciones entonces pues según si
se ve el el vaso medio lleno o vacío
pues ahí podemos ver qué pasa la
salvación del partido socialista dentro
de la coalición o que definitivamente
está demostrando que el partido ya no
tienen aquí sentar el pascal su opinión
sobre sobre este tema el futuro del
partido socialista y qué tan debilitado
está
bueno al nivel nacional definitivamente
la elección presidencia decidió un
desastre
en la candidata del partido socialista
el partido que gobernó récord de monos
de forza mi perro de
1981 hasta el 95 nos recordamos
obviamente de hong sobrando que dejó el
poder en 2017 pero que la candidata de
partido socialista haya obtenido
1.74 por ciento es desastroso y a la vez
el partido socialista tiene una
implantación territorial manda a unas
regiones en francia y ahí también pues
es una situación bien delicada para el
partido y lo vemos porque lo dijo bien
en la introducción es a esa eternidad de
de
ubicación que tienen unos líderes un ex
jefe del gobierno francés dijo vean acá
es nada pues anunció que salía del
partido que no compartía la opción de
unirse en esa nueva unión
pero no real
interesada por la francia insumisa es
decir pues que la crisis sea profunda
pero lo es también con un ex partido del
gobierno
los republicanos que surgen de partidos
de jacques chirac
de nicolas sarkozy es decir pues que la
verdad estamos entrando en un nuevo
tiempo político como bien lo vimos en
américa latina en los 80 en muchos de
los países de américa latina la
democracia cristiana estaba en el poder
aparecía como un partido muy fuerte y
desapareció a raíz de los 90 pues
estamos entonces ahí también en francia
en un momento creo de transformación de
mutación un cambio también está ligado a
generaciones la nueva práctica política
y en un tiempo muy particular no
olvidemos por cierto porque eso
condiciona también el esquema social y
económica que la guerra se asegurarían a
dos de vuelo de parís y estamos con esa
presión en la unión europea' y eso es
muy fuerte lo vemos con la temática de
la inflación lo vemos con la temática de
defensa y de independencia de la unión
europea lo vemos porque yo me lo sólo
hace lo dice también a través de la
temática de la nato de la de él quisiera
que francia saliese del mando integrado
de la organización del tratado norte del
atlántico pues visiones nuevas en
variedad nacional pero que ilustran un
tiempo muy particular de la historia de
francia y de europa pascal quiero que
profundicemos en ese tema que representa
para la política francesa este cambio de
generaciones digamos este paso de página
en la política del país al retirarse del
partido socialista françois hollande
que es
vasto no varias figuras que fueron
representativas en el pasado y que hoy
pues salen del partido qué significa
esto para la política francesa dice que
son aires de cambio pero profundicemos
bueno creo que significa que en primero
una ruptura interna en este caso de
partido socialista pero como apá como
como existe para todo lo gobierno
partidos que antiguo partido del
gobierno no están hechos para estar en
la oposición y menos para tener un 1.74
por ciento a una elección presidencial
es algo que no se podía imaginar
entonces por supuesto pues está
ilustrando esa ruptura con la opinión
pública primero una ruptura generacional
no creo que interese mucho que uno salga
en exeter a la opinión pública lo que le
interesa a los franceses hoy en día es
obviamente el temática del poder de
compra
suyo
no perder
ese poder de compra sentirse en
seguridad
tanto en la frontera nacional como en la
frontera europea
y tener esa entender esa visión de hacia
dónde vamos al nivel económico eugenio
por cierto y su referencia a la
transición ecológica pero debemos
recordar que durante el debate
presidencial y durante la elección
presidencial ha sido un tema esencial de
esa visión de transformación económica
bien si un tema que incluso entre lepén
y macro no quedó muy bien definido la
estrategia que puede tener francia - con
el momento que está viviendo europa por
la necesidad de abastecerse de petróleo
hidrocarburos de otro país distinto a
rusia es un tema transversal no
solamente en francia la transición sino
en los países de la unión europea del
continente entero pasó a preguntarle o
jim por las negociaciones que hay al
interior de estos partidos dentro de
esta coalición el tema de las
circunscripciones que es un tema muy
controversial allí tal parece que
francia insumisa dentro de estas
negociaciones logró como pactar que se
queda con 15 de ellas como es este
reparto como es esta negociación como
como es esta
negociación entre los partidos bueno hay
que saber que en el parlamento francés
hay quinientos setenta y siete diputados
es enorme es realmente enorme además los
franceses del exterior ahora tenemos
nuestros propios representantes es decir
que aquí hay unas luchas muy de arraigo
territorial digamos que la gente está
acostumbrada a votar por el partido
socialista por la derecha o ahora para
el egm dentro de una de una localidad
digamos y ahí france en su misa de dicho
bueno como yo mando la batuta entonces
yo sé que somos fuertes en tales
localidades y ahí pues queremos tener
candidatura única de nuestros candidatos
en estas ciertas localidades y lo que
quedó al partido socialista pues fue muy
poquito entonces es por eso que hoy en
el partido socialista estamos hablando
del cementerio de los elefantes' los
elefantes son los grandes líderes
socialistas que hoy en día pues
efectivamente dijeron si entramos en la
coalición o no queremos entrar en la
coalición y ya se fueron para el macro
mismo ya hace cinco años entonces queda
muy poquito sin embargo los electores
del partido socialista todavía existen y
ahí es interesante ver qué va a surgir
finalmente de este desmantelamiento del
partido socialista no olvidemos que la
derecha ha estado en esta posición con
nicolas sarkozy y que han cambiado de
nombre que han boleto a hacer un partido
pues aquí en la izquierda también el
partido socialista tiene algo que jugar
sin duda va a estar en minoría frente a
la francesa en su mismo pero hay muchos
candidatos que ahí están incitando entre
mayo y entre la coalición y sabemos que
más confiere estos estos electores
porque mucha gente ha votado por emanuel
más por menos' son perder la presencia
por descarte al marco pero no están
totalmente convencidos de las posiciones
de la fuerte la francia e insumisa por
eso emanuel mccone ha dicho que son y
menos yo no era extremista era peligroso
porque intentar robar este electorado
socialista que todavía sigue existiendo
y que el partido socialista de brilla en
los años a venir o abandonarlo al macro
mismo o volver a afrontar un nuevo
partido importante ese punto ya vamos
llegando a la recta final del programa
quiero hablar con pascal sobre un tema
que usted está mencionando en una de sus
respuestas anteriores y es uno de los
largos debates que se ha suscitado en
francia en los últimos días precisamente
por haberse discutido al interior de
esta coalición de izquierda y es esa
desobediencia a los tratados europeos en
materia económica y presupuestaria tema
importante ahí que se puede decir de
analizar sobre este tema pascal
pues es una forma de ahorros y sí mismo
clásico para la extrema izquierda en
francia ahora es uno de los puntos más
relevantes de diferencia entre la visión
de manuel macro y de sus apoyos y la de
la nubes de la unión de esa izquierda
plural
obviamente son híbridos aunque tiene
mucho talento para
oratorio que tiene cultura obviamente
pues dice pero nosotros no queremos el
éxito no queremos allí al igual
como en gran bretaña en el praxis que
franz a saliese de la unión europea
menos mal
francia es el país fundador de la unión
europea con alemania y los países del
tenis
y es uno de los países motores hoy en
día tiene la presidencia del consejo
europeo y está
defendiendo promoviendo la emoción de la
independencia de europa a nivel
energético al nivel de inteligencia al
nivel diplomático y directa pero
definitivamente no respetar considerar
que hay tal tratado la obligación de
limitar los déficit es a 3% por ejemplo
del producto interno de los países
existirá y escoger según el interés
natural nacional es absolutamente
incompatible con el funcionamiento de la
unión europea y obviamente mecánicamente
se va a poner una lógica de salida de la
música y dice que ahí hay un juego sobre
las palabras pero bien se ve pues esta
práctica es muy distinto
definitivamente claro ya estoy llegando
al final del programa eugene quiero
preguntarle por las coaliciones que
están haciendo los de centro y que están
haciendo los de la derecha frente a este
panorama y a lo que se viene para las
legislativas bueno entonces en el centro
tenemos de esta unión alrededor entonces
de la figura de manuel marco y en la
derecha pues no hay una unión digamos
tan fuerte magno y penn está haciendo
campaña por su lado erick sí mucho no
sabemos lo que va a hacer el próximo que
pensábamos que iba a ser la gran
sorpresa de estas elecciones que
finalmente quedó con el 7 por ciento de
elección de un porcentaje en las
elecciones presidenciales y que no tiene
realmente
personas para para lanzar a estas
elecciones que van a hacer será que se
va a haber una alianza y al nivel de la
república también que quedaron muy mal
parados no recordamos que también vale
gp casey son menos de 5 por ciento están
menos en dificultad porque ellos igual
que el partido socialista ya tiene una
larga trayectoria de política local y
tienen mucho más elegidos a nivel local
entonces no se ve digamos una urgencia
en la unión en la derecha como se ve la
izquierda es por eso que manuel marco en
este momento está ubicando todos sus
discursos en contra de ya no hay menos
porque definitivamente sabe que esta
unión puede ser su piedra digamos en el
zapato recordamos también que la
izquierda tiene un alto poder de
convocatoria en las calles claro que la
crisis de los chalecos amarillos todavía
queda viva en los imaginarios colectivos
y que seguramente en el macondo quiere
repetir este episodio y el malestar de
la pandemia y de la recuperación
económica sigue latente en la sociedad
francesa eso no ha disminuido entre los
franceses algo que complementar sobre
este tema pascal sobre las condiciones
de derecha a izquierda para pasar a las
conclusiones
bueno creo que ya el esquema político se
está cambiando hay un polo central
renacimiento ma cronista y ya aparecen
dos pilares de dos extremas por
alrededor por un lado de la francia en
su misa un polo de izquierda que la
ocupa de la izquierda social a una
izquierda más radical y por el otro lado
una derecha nacional de extrema derecha
es decir dos polos
antagonistas
radicales con esa mayoría que podría
aparecer y salir en el mes de junio no
se le ocurre para los próximos años pero
definitivamente estamos en tiempos
nuevos claro
bueno pues llegando ya al final del
programa quiero que hagamos las
conclusiones de lo que puede pasar en
esas elecciones parlamentarias como ven
ustedes el panorama de lo que pueda
suceder
y de ahí en adelante para francia y si
hay algún nombre para un primer ministro
en este país
eugene comenzó con usted el primer
ministro o la primera ministra todavía
no sabemos quién va a ser pero de manuel
mayo había asegurado antes de la segunda
vuelta que iba a ser de tomar una
persona que sea también muy bien
posición sobre el tema de la transición
ecológica eso era para atraer digamos el
voto de la izquierda y de los de los
verdes y efectivamente pero emanuel
marco está tomando su tiempo todavía no
ha dicho que iba a estar quien iba a
estar depende también de los resultados
un poquito de estas elecciones que puede
pasar seguramente no va a pasar nada
seamos sinceros seguramente manuel
mccomb va a tener la mayoría seguramente
la izquierda se va a volver la primera
fuerza de oposición en el país y la
derecha mal que bien va a acompañar en
el marco en alguna de sus iniciativas
gobierno eso sí el gobierno va a ser
plural eso sí tiene que haber caras
nuevas en manuel marco ha hablado de un
nuevo tiempo que su segundo mandato no
iba a parecerse al primero tiene que
proponer más mujeres más personas que
llegan de diversas fuerzas
y finalmente me va a terminar haciendo
un poquito un equilibrista para intentar
de dar oportunidad y satisfacción a todo
el mundo lo que es un esfuerzo bastante
complicado y se mantiene en cierta forma
el status quo 2 del gobierno como ha
venido haciendo a lo largo de los
últimos años pascal su conclusión me
queda un minuto pues creo que bien lo
dijo y manuel marco no se trata que
acaba de tomar posición para el segundo
período no se trata de administrar se
trata de acompañar un cambio un cambio
global en un momentos particulares y es
cierto que ya el próximo gobierno que va
a estar nombrado
seguramente en los próximos días con un
a un primer ministro va a hacer el
primer episodio de esa transformación
indispensable para que francia esté
fuerte en europa acompañando la potencia
europea y fuerte al nivel mundial pues a
pascal ya bien les agradezco mucho por
haber hecho este análisis para nuestra
france24 en américa latina' ya las
cartas están sobre la mesa y ya veremos
cuáles son los resultados de estas
elecciones parlamentarias en francia-
que están previstas para el mes de junio
son dos rondas ya veremos cómo se
resuelve allí y cómo se conforma la
asamblea nacional ustedes pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
de france 24 nos interesa conocer su
opinión por favor sigan comentando allí
y también sigan viendo france24
[Música]